well if you're pregnant you've probably
got tons of questions about
breastfeeding and what foods to feed
your baby
convenience and less stress for parents
just a few of the reasons mom and ceo
andrea ipolito started her own business
called simply fed
it's a tele-lactation feeding company
that works one-on-one with new parents
starting when they're pregnant and
through the growth of their baby
you'll be teamed up with international
board certified lactation consultants
to help you understand what's going on
with your infant's health
we've seen great interest in our
platform because
with covenant team you are nervous to
leave the home
with your baby and uh to go in public
but even before coven 19
it's hard to strap in your your newborn
baby into a car seat and go to a clinic
and so we provide support from the
comfort and safety
of their home and so they can access it
when they need it
where they need it andrea says the
service is covered by health insurance
she says you can also use your hsa
or fsa to cover these appointments just
head to simplyfed.com